DISCUSS THE GOP AGENDA IN 2018
AND WHETHER THE TRUMP AGENDA CAN
OVERCOME THE DEMOCRAT'S
RESISTANCE.
NEWT GINGRICH SAID THE GREAT
SURPRISE IN 2018 WILL BE THE
SIZE OF THE REPUBLICAN VICTORY.
ON THE OTHER HAND, A GOP
CONGRESSMAN IS NOT SEEKING
REELECTION AND NOT OPTIMISTIC.
>> WE FOR A CHALLENGING MID-TERM
ENVIRONMENT.
YOU TYPICALLY LOSE ABOUT 32
SEATS IN A MID-TERM.
MY COLLEAGUES ARE WELL AWARE OF
THE HISTORICAL CHALLENGESES AND
DONALD TRUMP COMPLICATES THAT
BECAUSE HE IS A POLLARIZING
FIGURES.
I EXPECT OUR CHALLENGES WILL BE
EVEN GREATER BECAUSE OF THAT.
>> GENTLEMAN, THE SPEAKER OF THE
HOUSE.
I AM NOT AWARE OF ANY SPEAKER
THATS THAT GONE UNSCATHED.
CONGRESSMAN GOWDY, HOW IS HE
DOING?
WHAT IS YOUR PERSPECT IDENTIFY
THE SPEAKER?
>> THERE ARE A LOTTED GOVERNOR
SAY THERE IS NO ONE BETTER
QUALIFIED TO BE THE SPEAKER OF
THE HOUSE THAN PAUL RYAN.
HE HAS EVER QUALITY YOU WANT IN
A LEADER.
HE IS SMART AND PRINCIPLED AND
INCLUSIVE.
HE IS RELUCTANT.
HE DIDN'T WANT TO BE THE SPEAKER
OF THE HOUSE.
HE WANTED TO BE THE CHAIR PERSON
OF WAYS AND MEANS.
WHEN McCARTHY DROPPED OUT OF THE
SPEAKER'S RACE WE HAD NO ONE TO
TURN TO.
WE SAID WILL YOU LEAD US?
HE RELUCTANTLY DID SO.
HE IS THE SMARTEST KID IN THE
CHOICE IF I STARTED THIS
GOVERNMENT ALL OVER AGAIN.
HE DID US A FAVOR BY TAKING THE
JOB.
I CAN'T THINK OF ANYBODY THAT
COULD DO THE JOB AS WELL AS HE
SUBCOMMITTEE CHAIRMAN ON CYBER
DOLLARS A YEAR OUR GOVERNMENT
SPENDS ON CYBER SECURITY.
IT'S A DANGEROUS THING IN THIS
COUNTRY.
WHAT KEEPS YOU UP AT NIGHT
LOOKING AT CYBER SECURITY AND
THE CHALLENGES FACING THE UNITED
STATES?
>> WELL, JASON, YOU AND TREY
HEARD HE SAY THIS BEFORE.
I CONSIDER CYBER SECURITY TO BE
THE GREATEST THREAT TO OUR
NATIONAL SECURITY.
LISTEN, I THINK WE ARE IN A FAR
INVASION OF OUR PHYSICAL
BORDERS.
SEE ANOTHER HACK THAT INCREASED
IN SEVERITY.
THE UNITED STATES WILL ONLY
REMAIN THE WORLD'S SUPER POWER
IF WE ARE ALWAYS THE WORLD'S
CYBER SUPER POWER.
AS MUCH AS WE ARE SPENDING IN
IT'S THE GREAT EQUALIZER.
CYBERSPACE IS.
IT'S HOW NORTH KOREA CAN COMPETE
WE HAVE TO DEDICATE OUR EFFORTS.
THIS IS AN AREA I ENJOY
LEGISLATEING IN.
WE HAVE TO DO THAT IN A SMART
WAY TO RAISE THE CYBER IQ OF
EVERY AMERICAN SO WE ARE SAFER
AND MAINTAIN THE WORLD STATUS AS
THE CYBER SUPER POWER.
>> A LOT OF ISSUES FACING THE
UNITED STATES.
COMING UP WITH BIPARTISAN
SOLUTIONS.
TREY GOWDY YOU HAVE BEEN WRITING
A BOOK WITH THE SENATOR FROM
THE TWO GUYS I AM WITH BUT TIM
SCOTT IS THE BEST PERSON IN
POLITICS.
AS YOU TWO KNOW, WE ARE
INSEPARABLE.
WE DID NOT KNOW EACH OTHER IN
2010 WHEN WE CAME IN AS
FRESHMAN.
WE HAVE CHOSE TONE HAVE A
FRIENDSHIP SOME WOULD CALL
UNLIKELY.
WE ARE MORE ENTERED IN THE
OUR RELATIONSHIP AND ENCOURAGE
OUR FELLOW CITIZENS.
I THINK THERE IS A HUNGRY FOR
CONCILIZATION FOR UNITY.
CONTRAST IS FINE.
I AM GLAD WE DON'T ALL PULL FOR
THE COWBOYS OR WATCH THE SAME
MOVIE AT THE SAME TIME.
WHAT I HEAR EVERYWHERE I GO IS A
DIVISIVENESS.
WE ARE THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA.
I WOULD LOVE FOR US TO SPEND
TIME CELEBRATING WHAT WE HAVE IN
COMMON AS WHAT WE DO HARPING ON
THE DIFFERENCES.
TIM, OUR HAIR IS DIFFERENT.
>> OUR HAIR IS DIFFERENT ON A
DAILY BASIS.
>> IF YOU PUT UP A PICTURE OF
TIM SCOTT, WE HAVE DIFFERENCES.
BUT WE MADE A CONSCIOUS EFFORT
TO CELEBRATE THE THINGS WE HAVE
IN COMMON.
JASON, I AM TELLING YOU, YOU
SERVE THERE WHETHER IT'S JOE
KENNEDY OR MORTON OR PETER WEST.
OO WELCH.
THOSE ARE ALL DEMOCRATS.
SOME VIEWERS DON'T WANT TO HEAR
IT BUT 99.9% OF US GET ALONG
WELL IN PERSONAL INTERACTION.
WE HAVE A HYPERFOCUS ON CONFLICT
IN THE COUNTRY.
THE FACT WE GET ALONG DOESN'T
MAKE THE NEWS.
WHAT MAKES THE NEWS IF THERE IS
ONE MEMBER ON EITHER SIDE
YELLING AT EACH OTHER.
I AM ENTERED IN UNITY AND THAT'S
WHAT TIM AND I WANT TO WRITE
ALWAYS TELLING ME TO ASK BETTER
QUESTIONS OF WITNESSES AT
HEARINGS.
SINCE HE IS OLDER AND WISER, I
WILL TAKE THAT ADVICE TO HEART.
>> DO YOU HAVE ANY WORDS OF
WISDOM OR GOOD MOVIE OR SHOW
THAT PROVIDES INSPIRATION?
>> I WISH YOU A HAPPY NEW YEAR
AND JOHNNY, YOU AND MITCHELL A
HAPPY NEW YEAR.
JASON A PRIVILEGE TO SERVE WITH
YOU.
JOHNNY, YOU ARE MY FAVORITE
MEMBER OF THE HOUSE.
HOLIDAY MOVIES.
ONE THAT I FOUND INSPIRATIONAL
IS NARCOS.
>> I THOUGHT HE WAS GOING TO SAY
BAD SANT.
>> [LAUGHING]